a conservative judge who is sanctioned
by the u.s for alleged human rights
abuses
won iran's presidential election today
he would replace a moderate the change
comes as iran and the u.s are
negotiating the terms of restoring a
2015 agreement
to limit iran's nuclear and ballistic
missile programs in exchange for the
lifting of u.s economic sanctions
elizabeth palmer reports from tehran
ibrahim raisi a cleric and hard-line
judge will be the new president of iran
on the surface the election looked like
any well-organized democratic contest
some voters were happy to discuss their
choice is everybody in your family going
to
vote for mr ricey yes did you discuss it
before
yes we talked about that
[Laughter]
others prefer to keep it a secret you
won't tell me
no you voted for
the candidate who will give you a better
life
government ads has stressed polling
stations would be coveted safe
and urged people to come to the polls
but everybody knows this was no open
contest 600 candidates applied to run
for president
iran's religious authorities picked
seven
not one of them offering true reform
millions of would-be voters decided
there was just no point
what are you going to do on election day
i sleep in a home
there is huge disillusionment with
iran's islamic regime
i did for 42 years
i didn't see anything to head off
an embarrassingly low turnout election
officials kept polling stations open for
an
extra six hours they finally closed
at 2 a.m
in spite of all that turnout was the
lowest it's been
since the revolution rye ec won by a
landslide
but in fact only roughly half of
eligible voters
bothered to cast a ballot for cbs this
morning saturday
i'm elizabeth palmer in tehran